So the answer is the third one. DNA RNA base pairing. Remember that Uracil
replaces Thymine in RNA, but that doesn't mean that Uracil from RNA can't base
pair with Adenine from DNA. Remember, the
ribose sugars are different. They're colored differently
in the RNA strand compared to the
DNA strand, but the letters, the nitrogenous bases,
can still pair with each other, right? So
here we have an RNA-DNA hybrid right now. Base
pairing is a powerful phenomenon, and as long as
you have these nitrogenous bases They want to form
these paired bonds with each other. So as
transcription occurs, a nucleotide after nucleotide is brought in
on the RNA side, it will keep being brought
in for the whole length of the gene until
transcription is complete, and you've reached the end. Now, when
I say the end, this isn't the end of the
chromosome. There actually is a distinct end to a gene,
and we'll talk a little bit more about that later.